do a hiker stranded in the desert for 40
hours recorded his
very terrifying experience listen
[Music]
robert ringo was on a hike in joshua
tree national park california when he
fell and broke his leg
he was in excruciating pain unable to
move he only had two
liters of water with him to stay
hydrated in the desert heat on top of
that
didn't even have a cell phone service or
anything to eat so he took all the
measures he could
i somehow scooted up this place ate some
juniper berries
and then came up on this flat plateau i
never got to the point where i thought
i'm not going to make this i just had a
confidence and a faith
confidence in a faith the search and
rescue helicopter team eventually found
him more than a day and a half later
ringo is okay and he says he's looking
forward to hiking again tony
just once i want to hear one of these
stories where somebody comes out of a
near-death experience and they say i'm
never doing that again
but all right i applaud his confidence
and his faith